but I heard you talking about it in and
talking about how you were intimidated
by his beauty yes I think we've got a
photograph of Ian as Coriolanus yeah
look at that
you do look great there Ian but check
out Patrick Stewart you've been hearing
about this amazing body it it is
absolutely amazing the privilege to be
so close but you know magneto the
character I used to play in this tie
though franchise was also a pretty a
muscular it wasn't here and there you
can see but the trick is that I am
wearing underneath my costume a suit
which is sculpted to look as if I've put
all this work out McKellen's working
just put on the suit and I'll tell you
what I've still got it at home I leave
you two got drinks and I don't yeah
we've got red wine everyone
red wine red look at that psychic God's
laws are and red wine
[Applause]
[Laughter]
what we're doing see you older people
what's all this about you being
circumcised you work together you work
together all on board what you did to
place together on projects are brilliant
oh yes you know that there are not many
plays where there are two wonderful
parts for actors of the same age so you
can go through your life never working
with the people you admire and the
people who you should have an awful lot
in common with Shakespeare's not bad it
to that extent but there are a few plays
and one of them is waiting for God oh
and there are two wonderful parts for
people of the same age and another one
is no man's man by Harold Pinter
and we've done them both and we've just
finished doing no man's land in London
though don't despair if you missed it
you can catch it on NT live they record
a performance the cinema and I have just
had an idea this is awesome for for some
time now I have been teasing Hugh but
getting more and more serious about a
theatre work job we might do together I
have been saying to this man for a long
time he should play Stephen Sondheim's
Sweeney Todd it is if the role might
have been written for him and I add a
writer that if he plays Sweeney Todd I
will for a limited run played the judge
which is a two scene role that with two
numbers including a duet between the two
of them who should play mrs. Lovett
[Applause]
[Music]